and more violence in New York City due
to the outof control border crisis with
tensions running high at makeshift
migrant shelters one fight even took a
deadly turn over the weekend the New
York Post describing those migrant tent
cities as helter shelter for good reason
Alexis McAdams is live from randles
Island in New York City good morning
Alexis hey Dana yeah a lot of things
unfolded over the weekend with the
migrant crisis here in New York City we
can tell you one migrant here in
randle's Island was stabbed at least one
time in his torso he was rushed to a
local hospital but he didn't make it
take a look on your screen this is where
it all unfolded here in Randall's Island
on Saturday night just after 7:00 there
happening right outside of that migrant
shelter and remember Dana these were
Sports Fields right for kids well
they're now home to these massive
migrant facilities you can see there
police responding to the area after the
guy was reportedly surrounded and
attacked investigators say he had more
than one Stab Wound and it was a
27-year-old migrant who was arrested for
this fatal stabbing now charged in
connection to this incident so this came
just hours after chaos erupted outside
of another Migrant Center in New York
City witnesses there say a migrant tried
to cut this long line you're looking at
where hundreds were waiting to sign up
for temporary housing they wait there
for hours for this that's when this
fight broke out two NYPD officers were
injured in the incident and at least two
guys faced charges in that case people
who live nearby say this line is always
snaking around the building listen there
are literally hundreds every day lined
up around the block all the way to the
next block and around the
corner so right now at least 70,000
migrants are being housed and fed by New
York City and more than 160,000 migrants
in counting have come to the Big Apple
since 2022 the New York Post also
reporting that over the weekend a group
of migrants were arrested for
shoplifting after reportedly trying to
run right out of a blooming Dales in
Manhattan with thousands of dollars
worth of designer sunglasses and that's
all just in the past 72 hours right Dana
so a lot happening here and we'll keep
an eye on what's going on at randle's
Island Dana all right Alexis thank you